game of thrones is absolutely full of
sex
and i'd like to thank you for that
because i enjoy that very much
oh good well you're welcome why
well life is very full of sex or it
should be
um you know i'm as
as much as i admire tolkien and i do he
was a he was a giant of
of fantasy in a giant of literature and
i think he wrote a great book that will
be read for
for many years but you do have to wonder
where all those hobbits came from since
you can't imagine hobbits having sex can
you
well sex is a important part of who we
are
it drives us it motivates us it makes us
do
sometimes very noble things it makes us
do sometimes
incredibly stupid things leave it out
and you've got an
incomplete world i get letters regularly
from people say oh i loved your books
until i
hit the pornography and now i will never
read them again because you're just a
dirty pornographer
i write back to some of them and i say
i'm sorry you feel that way you know you
can
you can skip over those scenes if you
want but although some of them
are important for revealing things about
character or
revealing plot points what i never get
any complaints about of course is the
violence
and this is uniquely american here that
i can describe in in exquisite detail
and acts entering a man's skull
and splattering blood and brains
not a peep i describe a penis entering a
vagina
in equivalent detail the world has ended
i'm actually having uh
a number of uh people naming their
children daenerys
they send me pictures of their babies
and sometimes bring them to my signings
three four years from now the first wave
of daenerys will be hitting kindergarten
and
and grammar school i wonder what the
teachers are going to make of this
they're going to have a hard time
spelling the name with all those a's and
e's and y's and things like that
i am the dragon's daughter and i
swear to you that those who would harm
you will
die screaming knowing how passionate
the fans are you still fearlessly kill
off people's favorite characters the
beheading of
ned starkin the first series was such a
shock to viewers
is this something you do lightly do you
write that line
in the book and then go downstairs and
simply have a cup of coffee
no no it's never easy
bring me his head
when when it happened in the book you
know a few reviewers made note of it oh
there's a shocking development at the
end
you know martin's not afraid to kill his
characters etc
but it was no big thing it was it was
a little ripple uh
when it happened in a tv show was like a
bomb had exploded on the internet went
crazy and youtube went crazy and
the emails started pouring into the show
and to hbo
and lots of reviews were oh my god no
one has ever done this sort of thing
before etc etc
if you're going to write a story about
war and intrigue and death and all that
you you have to
establish to your readers or your
viewers that
that you're playing for real that these
people are in actual danger
look at him
as the books go on you can never predict
who's going to stay alive and who's
going to die i think that's the most
important
it's completely real um you could you
couldn't predict the ending at all
i don't know where he's going i'd love
to um you know i'd love to meet him and
ask him
what his plans are for the future do you
know how the ice and fire series is
going to end
i do in broad strokes i know the ending
i know the fates of the principal
characters maybe not all the secondary
and tertiary characters but certainly
the the main players
i've known that you know for a long time
ago